elle la commanderie d-will comme le site
historique sur l encours fait peau neuve
pour sa nouvelle saison une saison
multiculturelle en y mêlant danse
rencontres musicales ou encore ateliers
scientifiques un fab lab enfin une sorte
d'incubateur qui va permettre quelques
expérimentations abu d'innovation chaque
plan culturel donc toujours dans le
thème de créativité en plus on va mettre
quelques thèmes un peu plus sur sur
l'activité ou sur le haut sur la
discipline scientifique et technique
les nouvelles technologies deuxième vie
sur avec des nouvelles étant de nos
jeunes aussi donc c'est pour ça que vous
avez toute une ambiance musicale
très ciblé aussi abuse cette population
de la musique avec un dj parisien des
démonstrations de danse et un café
éphémère pour se restaurer un avant goût
d'une saison qui fonctionnera au
trimestre nous allons faire des
programmes de trimestre en trimestre ce
qui nous permet d'ajouter des actions
des événements qui soit différente de ce
que nous on programme avec des
partenaires ce soit des associations des
compagnies ou les collectivités locales
intéressées
donc on a pensé par exemple organiser
des marches et circuits courts pour
permettre aux gens qui passent en
voiture tous les jours de s'arrêter
faire leurs courses elle la commanderie
reste aussi un lieu d'exposition pour
débuter ce premier trimestre c'est le
design européen qui est mis à l'honneur
avec une quarantaine de pièces issues
des collections du musée de la ville